going back to what you said when you
went to the franchisee
conventions back in the days i think the
blockbuster franchise fee was somewhere
between 150 000
to 700 000 it was a big number you
weren't paying
a small number you could end up paying
700 000 to get the whole thing going
when you went to the conventions at the
time and netflix is coming out and all
these other guys were coming out
did you hear the leaders at the top you
know
downplay that there's no way that's
going to work did you hear them bring up
netflix and other competitors regularly
or was there more
people are never going to get away from
running from a movie you know running
from a store like ours we're always
going to be in business
what did you hear from the messenger at
the top now obviously i'm saying this
i know you are now working for
blockbuster's franchisee with k
with ken and debbie and dish owns you so
it's not like you're calling out your
existing ceos
yeah i'm just trying to find out like
what it was like when you went to the
conventions
so there was you know when i first
started going to conventions i i was
like i said
new i mean i had only been with the
company for less than a year so
a lot of this stuff was pretty new to me
and i was really just dumbfounded by
the the kind of schmoozing
i guess you want to call it it was more
that the corporate
world would come in and oh yeah we're
franchise owners let's go in there and
and kind of you know they weren't really
giving us a lot of information or at
least wise
for me the average franchisee now i
don't know
you know we had the abf which was our
franchise business consultants they were
you know a big group and i know kim was
involved in that at one point
um and i know that they probably had
better communication with the
corporate blockbuster higher-ups than we
did as just the
franchisee sitting at the table in the
convention room but um
from what i saw was just a lot more of
them trying to
you know pass on the back hey you guys
are all doing a good job you know
kind of give us a lot of lip service i
mean i guess there's no other
you know positive way to say it i mean
that's basically what it felt like
and it didn't necessarily feel like they
were taking all of those things
seriously to us
it's like you bring up a conversation
it's like oh well we're doing this this
this and of course everything is all
positive
there wasn't you know you've been in in
conference meetings before
many with different businesses and you
know how it goes i don't want to hear
what positive things i want to see
action
i want to see results and it's like you
can give me all the lip service you want
you can tell me how wonderful it's going
to be
but if i don't actually see results and
i'm not getting any answers
then you're just you're just giving me
words coming out of your mouth to make
me happy because i'm here for three days
and then i'm going back home
and it's like you know i want to see a
real plan
of what we're going to do as a result of
this you know our numbers were starting
to go down and
and really here at our locations we were
um
we had the benefit of not having any
corporate stores around us
and we had a hollywood video here in
town we had some mom and pops but
you know we um we had four stores here
in bend so we definitely had
you know the bigger uh market i guess
you want to say or we have that
you know the bigger piece of the pie um
here in town and so we probably didn't
feel the effects that some of the bigger
towns felt
you know um in texas and different
places where they had lots of
corporate owned blockbusters and lots of
franchise owners so i mean we had
you know good producing stores and we
made good money here
at the time but we still were feeling
the effects of having redbox across the
street we were still feeling the effects
of netflix
you were still hearing customers coming
in going oh you work at blockbuster
blockbuster's old news
you know i i remember now when i walk
into costco people see me and recognize
me for blockbuster they're like super
excited and oh my god you work at the
coolest place ever
i remember when i go on the block or
into costco in different places and not
want to tell people
because i didn't want to hear about how
negative it was and how
you know not a business so i mean
it just was very frustrating for me
being a newcomer and seeing that hey
you know i'm not i'm not listening to
the same old same old that you're
telling me every time i don't see
results and i don't understand
why you people aren't taking this more
seriously and and you know the franchise
owners i could see the frustration
on their faces the actual owners i was
the manager and i was there and i was
there more to
you know find out what the new you know
pop which is what they called it which
was the new what what the stores are
going to look like you know what are we
going to do for christmas and what kind
of movies are coming out i mean i was
more
focused on that but i also worked in
business long enough to watch the other
things and
the franchise owners getting really
frustrated because they weren't getting
the
kind of the answers that they were
looking for they weren't getting the
support and the help and
um you know and they were paying an
enormous amount of fees i mean the
the amount of money that we were paying
to blockbuster every month was it was a
good chunk of money
to not be getting you know the the
answers so what was the number
was it ten percent or was it more like
six percent you know um i
i think it was closer to ten but i don't
know because well at the time remember
it's a big number yeah i was doing the
payroll and personnel stuff and i wasn't
doing the financial stuff so
that'd be more of a question for ken but
i know it was not it was not cheap
i mean we were definitely paying them a
good chunk and um
and definitely didn't feel like we're
getting our bang for a buck kind of a
thing
that's the thing that's the thing with
franchisee people don't mind paying the
money if the company at the top is doing
their part
it becomes problematic when you're doing
everything yourself and they're not
coming out with anything for that ten
percent you're paying
it can be very frustrating